rusia estaría lista para invadir ucrania
según denunció sin pruebas eeuu ante la
organización de naciones unidas
rusia ha acumulado más de 150.000
soldados alrededor de las fronteras de
ucrania en rusia belarús y la crimea
ocupada nuestra información indica que
esas fuerzas que incluyen tropas
terrestres aviones barcos se están
preparando para lanzar un ataque contra
ucrania en los próximos días israel
benjamin days las denuncias del
secretario de estado estadounidense
anthony blinken llegan luego de
conocerse la expulsión del vice
embajador de la unión americana en rusia
calificada como una provocación por
parte de washington y a la respuesta del
kremlin a la propuesta estadounidense
para desescalar el conflicto en la cual
le exige a washington dejar de entregar
armas a ucrania retirar las que ya
existen y el cumplimiento de los
acuerdos demmings
las exigencias finales de retirar las
tropas de determinadas zonas del
territorio ruso acompañadas de amenazas
de sanciones más duras son inaceptables
y socavan las perspectivas de lograr
acuerdos reales rusia volvió a dejar
clara su posición que no desea invadir a
ucrania no hay ni está prevista ninguna
invasión rusa a ucrania que eeuu y sus
aliados han estado declarando a nivel
oficial desde el otoño del año pasado a
lo que blinken pidió mayores garantías
- cede el gobierno ruso puede anunciar
hoy directamente sin evadir que rusia no
va a invadir a ucrania que lo diga
claramente directo al mundo y luego
demuestre lo al enviar sus tropas sus
tanques y sus aviones a sus hangares y
envía sus informáticos a la mesa de
negociación y el mundo va a recordar ese
compromiso
en medio de las denuncias el gobierno
ucraniano informó que al menos tres
personas resultaron heridas en fuego
cruzado con los separatistas pro rusos
en el este de ucrania y denunció que
algunos proyectiles impactaron en un
jardín de infancia sin dejar heridos en
el área dos días después de que el
presidente ruso
y calificará como un genocidio lo que
ocurre en la región del donbass durante
un encuentro con el canciller alemán
olaf scholz